looking out 50 years from now
what wins
virtual reality augmented reality
or physical reality
what wins meaning like what's uh yeah
what do people
of that have financial resources
enjoy spending most of their time in
i've always
been a fan of of of ar and it's kind of
an easy answer because if you if you're
wearing an ar device you put a bag over
your head it becomes a vr device you
know it just
it if you block out the
what's really there then all you're
seeing is
is is a vr
but you are with ar constrained
to to kind of operate in
something that's similar to physical
reality yeah with vr you can go into
fantastical worlds true true so
there are still issues in in those
fantastical worlds with um
with motion sickness
right so um
if if your uh
body is experiencing
acceleration your inner ear
um that this differs from what your eye
thinks it's saying then you'll get sick
uh unless you're a very unusual person
so it doesn't mean you can't do it it
just
it's a constraint that vr
designers have to uh to learn to work
with
so do you think it's possible that in
the future
we're living mostly in a virtual reality
world like
we become more and more detached from
physical reality
for entertainment maybe for certain
applications
i'm personally more
i mean we have to make a distinction
between what i would personally find
interesting and you know what might
win in the market so
maybe some people
maybe lots of people would like to spend
a huge amount of time in in vr um
i'm
personally more interested in um
enhancing the experience that i have of
the physical world because the physical
world is pretty cool
right and there's a lot a lot to be said
for
for moving around in the real world
you